Welcome to Ear Biscuits,
the podcast where two lifelong friends
talk about life for a long time.
I'm Rhett.
And I'm Link.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting.
Am I talking to Rhett.
I don't, am I talking to somebody else?
Am I talking to an alt alter ego?
I don't know, because
we're about to get into,
this is like breaking open the seal on a,
on something that you've been
keeping under wraps my friend.
Uh hum.
There's parts of this that
we're gonna discuss today.
I'm excited about because,
I think we're gonna discuss
it on a level that we haven't.
Well, because here's the interesting thing
is that by the time this podcast,
now we're recording a little bit earlier
because we're about to do some traveling.
And I have talked about this,
like on my personal social media, right?
In the podcast.
By this point.
But I haven't seen that yet.
But as I'm talking right now,
so few people know about this.
It's just kind of,
it's weird to be talking to you,
Ear Biscuiteers about it because--
And it is.
I've been thinking about
it for a long time.
What?
I have been working on a solo music
project under a name that is not Rhett,
but is still kind of my name,
'cause my middle name is James.
It's called "James and the Shame."
And it is a country music project,
essentially an album with some singles,
the first single dropped on
Friday called "Believe Me."
And we're gonna listen to that.
Yeah.
And talk about it.
In the next episode.
Another single coming in
August and then there's another
single and the album coming in September.
And this is a,
for lack of a better
word, is a concept album.
What's the name of the album?
Well, that's interesting
because am I committing to it right now?
What do you mean?
You don't know?
I have something.
Okay, save it.
I have something in mind, but I'm gonna,
I might know by the time this goes live,
but I haven't fully committed.
I wanna discuss that.
You're playing the marketing game with me.
I don't know the name of the album.
No, I have a name in mind.
Okay, but you're not gonna say
that you're not gonna release this.
'Cause I might change it slightly.
You're gonna release the track list.
Like a.
I don't know.
But anyway, it is a.
That's what artists do, man.
I'll get into the,
I'm gonna get into all the
details of why this is happening,
how this happened, how
long it's been, whatever.
Who the features are.
Yeah.
Also who the features aren't.
Hmm, yeah.
But what I will say.
What I'm saying is I'm not featured.
It is a.
We'll talk about it.
It is an exploration of my spiritual
deconstruction through the
means of country music.
And so I tried to come up with a cool way
to describe that like.
Yeah.
Deconstruction and country,
but all I came up with is Decountry,
which is.
That's not it,
Which is not great so.
That's not it.
You're still trying to figure out how
to talk about this project.
This is an interesting thing,
because this is not like,
this isn't my day job.
My day job is what we do.
This is my hobby and my side gig.
Interestingly, you've
got this new crazy watch
that you're wearing for the first time.
And it's making all kinds of light.
Oh, it's analyzing everything.
But it's like shy, almost shy.
It's so loose, right?
Why's it so loose.
'Cause it's so loose
when you go like this,
it's shining in my eye.
I'm sorry, Christy said the same thing.
I gotta figure it out.
I gotta figure out I, if I wanna.
Christy said it was too loose.
She said it was shining in her eyes too.
It's like a robot.
Well, it's analyzing like my biometrics
But it needs to be tightly analyzing it.
Not like from a distance.
But I feel like if it gets too tight,
then my hand will fall off.
Well that's a whole nother episode.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm not making this about me.
But what I'm getting at is,
this isn't something that I've been
like scheming and thinking
about in a really strategic way.
It's a very organic thing that just,
so this is actually,
a lot of the things that
I'm saying right now,
the first time I've thought about them.
First time I've thought about,
and I actually made the
commitment to myself.
Like last night I was like,
should I think about what I'm gonna say?
I was like, no,
that's what this forum is for.
I'm just gonna think about it out loud
because I've just been focusing on
getting the music done and being happy
with the music and a couple of the things
that you have to do.
You gotta have album art.
Okay and that kind of thing.
But I haven't been
thinking about this from a,
how am I gonna talk about this
to people who aren't already
our fans and already Mythical
Beasts, somebody who's like,
I'm just a person who
listens to country music.
And there's a new artist out there
and I'm gonna check 'em out.
Well, they're not listening to this.
What?
So this is different.
Yeah, well, we'll talk about that.
Who I think it's for.
Yeah, but we know who's listening to this.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
Just Mythical Beasts.
If I may make a suggestion
about like formatting of this thing.
I would like to talk about the project
and really get into the details of it
and kind of to the point
we were just making
for this audience and for this venue,
what I don't wanna do is,
I don't wanna start making it about
like, what does it mean for us first?
But I would like to get into that.
Yeah, we'll talk about that.
Like I think that,
listeners will be interested in like,
how has this played out
in terms of our dynamic
for you to be doing this solo project?
Yeah.
Rhett going solo.
What's my take on that?
What are both of our
experiences with you doing
the first bonafide solo project?
Even if it is a side
project and a hobby thing,
I think that's something
for us to work out,
not work out, but something
for us to just talk through.
Yeah.
We talked through it a little bit,
but I think that would be a good edifying,
conversation for us.
And it might answer some
questions that people have.
Like what is it, because I'm sure.
Actually that wasn't one of my
worries in doing this thing.
We'll talk about that.
We're gonna say, like you said,
you're gonna save that for the second half
of the conversation.
Let's talk about how this happened.
That that's exactly what I'm saying.
Let's save it for the second
half of the conversation
after we've just talked about
the project in and of itself.
Okay.
Okay, so how did this happen?
How did this happen?
And can I just make a quick plug?
Yeah.
Because it's very timely.
As of the release of this episode,
I'm doing an AMA,
every month we do an AMA
on the Mythical Society.
It's on Discord.
But you're going solo to this AMA.
I'm actually going solo,
but I'm bringing on another guest, Lilly.
So Lilly, my daughter and I,
are doing an AMA on the
Mythical Society today
at what is the day's date?
Today is July 18th in the year 2022.
Yep.
At 3:30 Pacific, 6:30 Eastern
on the Discord of the Mythical Society.
We're doing an hour long AMA.
So tune into that.
And if you're listening to this later,
all the AMAs,
the ones we do every single month
and the one I'm doing with
Lilly today will be archived.
So you can like read
through all the questions
in our answers and so that's today.
So let's get into it, James.
Should I call you James the rest of today?
Yeah.
Call me what you want to.
I say, yeah.
James is the name I use when
I order food from any place,
including Starbucks,
'cause it's a name people can understand.
But now it's your.
But now it's my,
I wouldn't call this an alter
ego because an alter ego
is you purposely tried to
disassociate yourself from,
and this is just like Rhett
James McLaughlin, who is me,
has a solo music project that
is called James and the Shame.
I'm still working on the
best way to explain that.
But we'll talk about why I'm not just,
hey, why aren't you just Brett McLaughlin?
We'll get to that.
So how did this start?
So obviously,
I have a guitar let's let's start there.
I don't think I know the
answer to this by the way.
Yeah.
I'm very, very interested.
So the two of us have
written and recorded,
I actually, it's funny 'cause
as I was putting together
the bio that's gonna be
like on Spotify, etcetera,
you and I have written and
recorded over a hundred songs,
easily over a hundred.
It might be close to 150, but like.
Wow.
And so because I wrote something
like a stark departure from his over
100 multi genre comedic songs written
and recorded as part of
the duo Rhett and Link.
Should have said a Lonely Island.
That would've helped you.
I think we've written and recorded
way more songs than Lonely Island.
Maybe not as good, but a lot more.
We're more prolific in certain way,
in terms of the number of tracks,
but we've written a lot
of music and you know,
the majority of that music was written
in a way where it was like I had a guitar
somewhere and I would like come up with
some rhythm and structure and
just like put it in a voice
memo and then show up and
we would write to it, right?
So it has been a habit
over the past 20 years.
I've got a guitar in
every place that I go.
I've got a guitar in the office.
I got a guitar in my bedroom,
but we tend to get really busy with things
and I'll go months without
picking my guitar up.
And we just get so deep
into some new project
that may or may not have music.
And if it doesn't have
music, it's just like,
I'm not picking my guitar up.
My fingers start, I was like,
ah, I don't have callouses anymore on my,
like they wear off.
But I think it was 2019 and my guitar
is in my bedroom and I pick it up
and I'm kind of like just
diddling around on it.
And the next thing you know I'm.
Diddling yourself.
I'm beginning to write and this is unusual
because I've never done this.
In the past 20 years,
if I start playing something
and start singing something
and start writing something,
it is always exclusively
what I would call a business decision.
Hmm.
Okay?
It means I am writing this
song as part of the mythical
thing that me and you have built together.
And it is obviously going
to be for the purpose,
it's comedy song.
We could use this in
something or whatever,
or I need to write a song
for Buddy System soundtrack
or something like that, right?
Right.
Which I think is the last
time we were really intensely
writing songs was Buddy System Season two.
And it was so.
Actually it was the music for the tour.
That's right.
We wrote the few songs.
We came back and we wrote.
The few new songs that we like,
Why I Travel, Kyle, The Shirt Song.
Which interestingly enough, like,
so Buddy System season two,
it was very collaborative.
It was very last minute to the point
where we were going on separate vacations,
right before filming.
And we had to divide up songs,
something we had never done.
Yeah, 'cause we were so under the gun.
We were so under the gun.
I had to write one song.
You had to write another song.
And we had to commit that we were both
gonna bring them back basically done.
Yeah.
Which was unusual.
And then for the tour,
the Rhett and Link Live Tour in 2019,
you wanted to start playing piano.
And so then you were like,
you made yourself write
Why I Travel on the piano.
That really wasn't.
I didn't add too much to that
song as much as I recall,
I don't recall doing much to it.
And then in the other ones like Kyle,
that was a little more collaborative.
And The Shirt Song just isn't memorable.
I mean, it had memorable.
The Shirt Song is a performance art.
It's not really a song
that you wanna listen to.
Yeah.
It's a song.
But those.
It's a song you might wanna watch after.
You just kind of went
away and wrote those,
'cause again we were in this divide
and conquer mode and music,
and the tour was kinda like
get in where you fit in kind of thing.
Yeah.
So there was a little bit
of, even in that yeah.
You would sit,
you started more and more initiating
Rhett and Link songs on your own.
Yeah.
But this time in 2019, you sat down,
you weren't thinking
about a business move,
you weren't thinking about an obligation,
a creative obligation.
I was like, I've got this idea.
And really it wasn't like
I'm going to sit down
and write a song.
It was like, I'm playing the guitar.
And I kind of like what I'm hearing here
and I'm just starting to
kind of sing a melody.
Usually I'll sing a melody
that is nonsensical.
Words that just sound good
and I'll make a voice memo
just so it's just like,
oh, I wanna remember this
melody that I came up with.
And you sing words that sound good,
that don't make sense, right?
It's a very common songwriting technique.
And so, but I was like,
I was saying words that did make sense.
And I realized that I was
writing a song to God.
Okay?
So writing a song to God.
Oh.
And when I say writing a song to God,
as someone who doesn't
necessarily believe in God
at this point,
I was writing a song to the idea
that I had of God in the past.
And you know,
basically writing a song like
I had a relationship with you.
So if you don't know.
Do you remember the first line
that kind of came out of it?
I still remember when we used to talk,
you never said much,
but I knew what you thought.
Hmm.
Huh.
So that was the first line that came out.
And so I was like, oh,
this is kind of like,
if you don't,
if you're not a Christian
or a former Christian
or a spiritual person,
maybe you wouldn't pick up
on the thematic imagery here.
And you might think I'm just writing
a song about a lost love,
because it's about a
relationship that you had.
I've got these old letters,
it's called Old Letters.
I've got these old letters
that you wrote to me.
And I sit down and read
'em, the Bible, you know?
I don't like giving all the,
I want you to listen to the music
and interpret it for yourself.
But this one's pretty obvious, I guess.
But I was writing it and I was like,
I don't know who this is for.
I don't know why.
I don't know.
I'm writing a song because I'm going
to have a music project one day.
It was very much just like,
oh this is coming out of
me in a very easy way.
And I'm not,
it's interesting 'cause
I'm not trying to be funny.
There's no jokes in this song.
It's very serious and it's very sincere.
Hmm.
And it happened very quickly.
That's one of the things about almost all,
there's 11 songs on the finished album
and all of them.
The process between beginning
to write and then record
or like fine tuning the lyrics,
that may have been a months long process.
But with rare exception,
the writing of the music and
the first pass of the song
is usually something that happens
when I just sit down and do
it in about one to two hours.
And then you go,
I've got a song, right?
I'm gonna come back,
I'll change that lyric.
I'll work on that, whatever.
But they usually come out really easy.
If I sit down and it's this hard I'm like,
I'm doing this for fun.
It's not a business decision.
It's not a job.
So there's no forced creative.
So this first song.
Letters.
Yeah.
It pretty much came, it
formed in that sitting.
And then what?
So I sat down and like recorded,
I recorded a demo of it,
but I wouldn't have called it a demo.
I was just like,
oh, I'm gonna record this.
And I actually recorded
it in like the Evernote audio record.
I don't know if you've ever done this,
but like Evernote has, you
can press add audio and it,
so it is so low quality.
It sounds like something like out
of the twenties compared to like,
if you just do a voice memo
and attach it, interestingly.
And I was just like, okay, I did that.
Now this is 2019.
At some point after that, I
would say months after that,
I just kind of told my therapist about it.
I was like, yeah, I wrote,
we were having lots.
Can you pull it up?
Play a little bit of it.
I don't wanna do that.
'Cause that's not, that's not the.
That's not the single.
Okay.
It's actually the last song on the album.
Maybe I'll play that when,
'cause you can see how different
the final version ended
up being, or maybe,
That's fair.
Or once the album comes out.
But I I'm talking to
my therapist about it.
And we were having a lot
of broader conversations
about me getting into a place
where I was in creative flow
and him just making rec,
just recognizing like
seems like when you are,
you're healthy and you're thriving
and you're experiencing joy,
when you're in a creative flow.
Now obviously I'm in a creative flow a lot
with what we do for a living,
because this is a creative business.
This is a content business.
So that I'm doing lots of writing.
I'm doing a lot of creative things,
but it's also a very
sophisticated business
with a lot of moving parts
and those business
parts, which I do think,
that both of us are really good at,
isn't necessarily life giving
and doesn't breathe a lot of joy.
It's kind of like, well,
if you wanna do this right,
you gotta do this right.
So you gotta answer
these business questions,
etcetera, etcetera.
Yeah.
For other people business
can get 'em into flow,
but that's not really our thing.
Yeah.
And so he would,
my therapist without giving specifics
was just like saying like,
yeah, you should just,
I'm telling him about writing a song,
he's like, when you talk about that,
I kind of see you light up a little bit.
So I would just encourage
you to continue to just
express yourself creatively
and move towards things
where you can express yourself creatively.
He wasn't being like, go do an album.
So it wasn't like, okay,
yes, I'm gonna do that.
It was like, yeah, yeah.
I really enjoyed that.
Maybe I'll do it again.
Pandemic roles around, 2020.
Oh yeah.
And our lives changed
drastically like everyone else's.
We were obviously still really busy.
We were doing everything that
we were doing with Mythical
and trying to keep all
our content streams going,
but you know, less
travel more time at home.
I got this guitar in my bedroom.
I got a guitar at the Creative House.
I got a guitar here.
I got guitars everywhere, right?
And so I just found myself
as a way of sort of like passing the time,
picking up my guitar
and beginning to play.
And I just started finding
that every time I did that,
a song would come outta nowhere, right?
Hmm.
And so then, before I knew it,
I had written a song to my parents.
I had written a song to my children.
I had written a song to my wife.
I talked about the song that
I wrote for Valentine's D.ay
We talked about on the podcast.
Yeah.
That I played for her,
which is a song that I
ended up writing for her.
Oh yeah.
You're talking,
you're not talking about
when you were dating.
You're talking about like.
I did it when I was dating too.
I'm talking about like.
You did a 2020.
It's probably 2021 Valentine's Day
is when I probably talked about it.
Okay.
What was happening was
is without any real calculation,
all the songs that I was
writing were more like,
it was a cathartic sort of therapeutic way
of thinking about my deconstruction.
So I point out those songs
and one to my parents,
one of my kids, one of my wife as,
what was happening with me
is I've had this very long
process of deconstruction.
And as I've talked about many times,
my spiritual deconstruction on its surface
is it was a very
intellectual thing, right?
I wasn't wronged by someone emotionally.
I didn't have a pastor do me wrong.
I wasn't like,
I didn't have the rug pulled
out from underneath me.
It was just a very slow process
of access to new information
that was increasingly more
difficult to reconcile
with my Christian worldview,
to the breaking point.
Right?
But that doesn't mean that
there weren't incredibly heavy
emotional things happening,
relational things,
like deconstructing from a faith
that your parents gave you.
And they still have.
Being a father to kids
when they were born.
You're taking them up
in front of the church
and dedicating them to God
and then no longer believing in that God
in the same way and no longer adhering
to a biblical or Christian
worldview and still
wanting the best for them.
Like what is that?
So what I would find is that
the way for me to process
all these emotions was
to write a song about it.
So I started talking more
and more to my therapist about this.
And he was like,
this is bringing something out in you,
and just started talking
to Jessie about it.
And she was like,
it's not,
anyone who knows me well knows that it's,
I am a very emotional person,
but on the surface
you don't see that,
but there's a lot going on.
You gotta kind of tap
into it and you gotta,
it has to come out in a
certain way for you to be like,
oh, this dude was feeling
a whole lot of things.
Hm hm.
And so I just kept going and going.
And again, the thought as
I was writing these songs
was this is a therapeutic
cathartic process.
Now of course I am a
full-time entertainer.
And so as I'm getting to like
the third and fourth song,
I'm like, I'm making something here.
Yes, I'm doing this for myself.
Yes, it is a therapeutic process.
Yes, I do feel like
there's like an emotional
release every time I do this,
but I'm making something here.
It's kind of, yeah.
There's at tension of,
you're doing something for therapy,
but then you're also,
you're not just a creative person,
but you are an entertainer.
And so it's, I mean,
there's echoes of the conversation
that we had about like,
why you're growing your
hair out like this,
it originated in therapy
and you were like,
it was a therapeutic exercise,
but at a certain point,
you're like, I actually
think I will look good
with my hair like this.
I think my wife will like me better.
I think that this fits into my brand.
These things are things that
you can't help but think about
because of the position
that you have in life.
Well, and not just that,
it's also my personality
as an Enneagram three,
which I don't,
not everybody,
some people get tired of
hearing about the Enneagram.
I get it.
But the Enneagram three,
just think about it this way.
It just means your performance minded.
It means that you find
your value and your worth
in what you perform for
people, in winning, right?
Right, so there's.
And it's very unhealthy.
It can be very unhealthy.
And it goes with you into every endeavor,
even like something that
like nothing for anybody is,
is like absolutely pure.
It's like, we're not, you know?
Yeah.
But that doesn't mean
you can't be aware of it
and still like,
I believe that this can be
a relatively pure endeavor.
Well, it's funny 'cause I have a song
that I've already written.
I've written multiple additional songs
that are not on the album
that I guess will be for
something in the future.
But one of them is about
this exact process.
Huh.
That talks about,
I ain't sure what I'm trying to prove
or who I'm trying to prove it to.
You know what I'm saying?
Like that's the treadmill that
the three is on constantly.
Which is really me.
I wrote it when we,
I finished the the album
and I'm thinking about this process
that I'm in right now, which you know,
'cause I've been telling you about it.
It's one thing to write the music
and I love the process of writing.
I love the process of recording.
I love the process of
collaborating with talented people
who make what I wrote better
than it would be if I
was the one in charge
from the beginning to the end.
I love all that.
But as I get into the
process of like, okay,
well you have to like have a
bio and you gotta have like,
you gotta get pictures taken.
Once I started beginning to
do these things that feel very
performative and marketing oriented
is when I started thinking
about the built-in
irony of doing something
that is personal, cathartic,
therapeutic, beneficial to me
and then turning it into
a consumable product,
which is checking all the
threes performance boxes.
So I wrote a song about that,
but it's not on the album
because it's about the
process of doing this, right?
But just to go back.
Yeah.
So at a certain point you had
amassed a number of songs.
Like what was,
you made a decision that you
were gonna make this an album?
Well, when I got to like four songs,
I was like, ah,
two more songs and I've got like an EP.
I mean you can do a four song EP,
but I was like a six song
EP, like that's respectable.
That's something.
I can write two.
So, but that process was very
much, it wasn't calculated.
It was like,
as I would keep talking about this stuff
with my therapist and with Jessie,
I'd be like you know,
I feel like these songs need
to be released into the wild.
They need to be put into the world.
And here's my thinking on that.
So, you know that I'm a
big fan of David Bazan
Pedro the Lion,
he's probably even more
known for his band.
That's his band name.
So he is a guy that grew
up in a Christian home
and was very much a
strong, very similar story.
And then he deconstructed
and he was actually making
like Christian music,
I think back in the day
with Pedro the Lion.
And then of course he
deconstructed and it kind of,
his music evolved with his worldview,
but he made an album
probably in the late, alts,
like 2008, 2009,
called Curse the Branches.
It was curse your branches
or curse the branches.
And it was essentially his
deconstruction album, right?
And it was a little bit of an angry album
in that he was kind of like, he was,
a little bit angry at the
world that he had come from,
but also it was just deeply.
It was so thoughtful.
And so like specifically
connecting to what I,
now I wasn't listening
to it in 2008, 2009,
when it came out,
I listened to it probably
almost 10 years later.
Yeah, I listened to it once.
And.
It just, yeah, it was a bit of a downer.
Yeah, but I was just like man,
this is so meaningful to me
because of my particular experience.
Yeah.
And I was like you know,
I'd love to make the album
that I would want to listen to, right?
I've heard that before,
write the book that
you would want to read.
So I was like, okay, I'm
gonna make this music.
It's the music that I would
want to listen to as someone
who's kind of been through
or going through what I went through.
And so then it was like,
this could be a gift to
those people who have,
who can relate to this story.
And not just people who, again,
this is a super niche thing.
Again, it's very much a country album,
which is not necessarily
like the most popular genre of music,
but it's the genre of
music that I can personally
write and sing in a credible way.
Let's get more into that
after listening to it.
But it's also personally
my favorite type of music.
But the subject matter is
very, at least for this,
this album is very
specific because every song
is related to that process.
Yeah.
And again, that's when it
became this thing like,
well, this should be something
that is released because
it's so deeply personal and emotional.
And I know that there's so
many people out there going.
This is a cultural movement.
We talked about it many times.
People reevaluating their
traditional worldviews,
whatever your traditional worldview,
doesn't have to be
Christianity specifically.
But like we're in an era
where you're bombarded
with so many perspectives
and so much information that it's becoming
increasingly difficult to
hold onto any traditional view
that requires putting your
blinders on and blocking out
everyone else's perspective.
And so this is a cultural upheaval,
which I think ultimately
will be for the best.
But so many people can relate that,
I hope that regardless
of their circumstances,
it'll be like, ah, this,
you can connect with this music
and it can be a gift to people, you know?
So that's when it became
like I'm gonna release this,
but that was all that happened.
But of course I hadn't
recorded anything beyond demos.
And so this is the second
piece of the puzzle,
because I didn't know how
it was gonna become a thing, right?
We developed a relationship
with Derek Furman,
who was Britton's producer on your cousin,
Britton Buchanan on his stuff.
And he started producing our music
for the ethical society.
The Lionel Richie stuff,
the Brooks & Dunn stuff,
the Hazel, the Hazel project.
Yeah.
And just love the dude
and just love the way that
he commits to a project
and just is super technical
and just like really
gets involved and can do,
can execute very well
in a number of genres.
So I was just like talking
to him and I was like,
hey, I got these songs
that I've been writing.
What would it look like if you
recorded and produced them?
And of course, he was
like, I love this idea.
And so getting someone else
involved in the project.
Yeah.
That light's a fire.
And then you begin moving forward
and it moves from just
being a hobby and a pastime
A production.
This is good.
This is gonna be a thing.
Again, from a timeline standpoint.
I made that commitment last year.
So that was 2021.
Was talking to him about it,
like the middle of the year.
And I was like, I don't know
when this is gonna come out.
Probably 2023.
That's what I told him.
I was like, I don't want
you to prioritize this.
I cannot prioritize this because
I can't work on this 'cause
it's very, very busy.
Have a lot of other things going on.
This is a nights and weekends thing for me
and if you want it to be a nights
and weekends thing for
you, then I was like,
don't stop working on
something to work on my thing.
But I'll send you things as I have 'em.
Send you demos.
So that was kinda the process,
but he would like turn
something around and like,
I'd be like, man,
that sounds a lot better
than my demo, you know?
And I kind of got addicted to the process.
And I was, why am I
only gonna do six songs?
I got more songs.
And I was like, there's
a lot of different.
The thing that sent me to 11 songs
was trying to cover the
breadth of the experience.
I was like, well,
there's this other aspect
that I really want to talk about?
And then I was like,
also, I kind of feel that
there needs to be like a thesis
statement that is sort of
the beginning of the album.
It's the first song,
which is the first single
and that's believe me,
which was one of the,
was written pretty late in the process
because it was stepping back
and looking at what I
had done and thinking
about this would be a
good thesis statement,
a good opener to where I'm
gonna kind of take you through
conceptually on the album.
And so that's how I ended
up getting to 11 songs.
Okay.
And the last thing I'll talk about
before we actually listen to the single,
is why it's called James
and the Shame, right?
Why is it not Rhett McLaughlin?
So at some point early
on, I had this idea that,
well, what if this was like a covert thing
that I didn't even talk about,
but I just put out there.
And then I started thinking about the fact
that so much of,
if the whole point of this
thing is to connect with people
who are experiencing something
similar or can relate,
well, one of the things
that has been such a,
has brought those people
out of the woodwork
is me sharing these things through
the public forum that I have
as the public person that I am.
Yeah.
And so I was like,
it doesn't make sense to not talk about it
or try to make it seem
like there's just some new country guy's
talking about spiritual things.
And if you wanna know about it, you can.
But I was like, but I don't
want it to be Rhett McLaughlin.
I don't want it to be my name.
I want it to be something that is like,
hey, this is something outside
of everything else that this guy does.
When you hear the name, Rhett McLaughlin,
you think Rhett and Link comedy.
I'm not supposed to take this seriously.
When is the joke?
When is the first punchline
coming in this song?
Right?
And also, I don't.
It becomes pretty obvious pretty quickly.
And I didn't want it to be
a distraction for somebody
who stumbles across it in a playlist
or something on Spotify to
be like Rhett McLaughlin?
If what I have put out into
the world professionally,
which is a bunch of lighthearted,
silly stuff to take your mind off things,
isn't your cup of tea.
I don't want you to not
wanna listen to this,
if this would actually be
something you'd be into.
Yeah.
So that's where James
and the Shame came from.
James and the Shame,
not only does it rhyme,
it kind of roll off the tongue, but again,
shame is the dominant sort of emotion
of the Enneagram Three,
of someone who is performance minded.
So the twos,
the threes and the fours in the Enneagram
are all in the heart triad.
And that means that there's
a whole lot going on in here
that they try to deal
with in certain ways.
And the way the three
deals with their shame
is to try to keep performing for you.
Don't, just keep watching,
watch me do cool things.
And you won't have to know who I really am
and who I'm ashamed of.
Hmm.
And so that whole idea of
James and the Shame is like,
obviously the shame means two things.
Number one, this was not
a, it is a solo project.
I wrote all of the music
and all of the lyrics,
but the final production
includes some other very talented
musicians who played
different instruments.
And so I guess in some ways
that represents the other people
who collaborated to make
these final products,
but also more so than that,
it's the shame that follows
me around wherever I go.
It's like, you got James
you got the shame too.
But let's listen to this song, man.
Okay.
But first let's do a quick plug.
Alright.
Stevie's podcast comes back.
We wanna show some love to
Best Friends Back, Alright!
Her and Neagheen.
Their friendship is.
Blossomed.
It's happened.
And now they're branching
out into other things.
I'm told that they're gonna
be getting Neagheen's sister
who's a gynecologist.
Yeah.
On an episode.
I can always learn stuff
from a gynecologist.
They're not just talking about,
their high school days now,
now that they've rekindled the friendship,
they're moving into just the
things they wanna talk about.
So check out Best Friends Back, Alright!
wherever you get your podcasts.
Season two, it's out now.
It's happening.
They're turning another corner.
Another corner.
Alright, you ready to play this thing?
Yes.
Okay, so this is.
When you played it for
me, I listened to it,
I think three times in a row.
And then at a different
occasion, I heard it again.
I've only heard this song four times
and I've only heard another song once.
There's only three songs
that are mastered right now.
Okay.
But yes, this is.
I'm told there is an
album, I just don't know.
So this is the first single.
It's called Believe Me,
it was released on Friday the 15th.
So you can go to wherever
you listen to music
to listen to it, but we're
gonna play it right now as well.
♪ I think you want an answer ♪
♪ I'm not prepared to give ♪
♪ 'Cause the one I gave you ♪
♪ Said that that ain't it ♪
♪ Must be something that I want ♪
♪ Fame and fortune or
at least a little dawn ♪
♪ It may seem too cut and dry ♪
♪ I just found some things I
could not brush off aside ♪
♪ Now if you'll oblige ♪
♪ I don't think it's true ♪
♪ I'm not asking you to agree ♪
♪ I'm just asking you to believe me ♪
♪ Say my heart is never true ♪
♪ That might say more about you ♪
♪ I know it shouldn't matter ♪
♪ If you take my word ♪
♪ When I say I didn't
leave cause I was hurt ♪
♪ But there goes my pride ♪
♪ With his refrain that
I be seen as justified ♪
♪ Likely nothing I could say ♪
♪ And I'm not sure care
for me to explain ♪
♪ Sure you can pray ♪
♪ But I don't think it's true ♪
♪ I'm not asking you to agree ♪
♪ I'm not asking you to believe me ♪
♪ You say my heart is never true ♪
♪ That might say more about you ♪
Ha, ha, ha.
I love it man.
The first time you
played this song for me,
I was blown away.
I don't know what the
look on my face was but.
You started smiling really early.
I mean, yeah,
right at the beginning, because like,
I'm a sound guy before a lyric guy.
Right, right.
And so I was just relieved
that it was really good.
What did you it was gonna be,
'cause I was telling you about it,
but I was pur and this is,
we can kind of start
getting into the dynamic
of like how me and you
related about this because.
Yeah.
I was very much, I didn't want,
I wanted to have something to show you.
Well.
That was done.
I think that was, I'm glad that I didn't,
I didn't hear anything.
I mean, hearing what you just played
is the first thing that I heard of it
Right.
Specifically.
No demos, no sneak peeks, no nothing.
Right.
But I mean the production,
I mean I knew Derek was great
and I knew he was gonna do
something great with it.
And you had told me that
he was hooking you up
with like studio musicians,
some in Nashville,
some in LA, right?
That were like adding, they were adding.
I mean it wasn't,
they were adding their
stuff and sending it in.
Yeah, well,
we thought we were gonna go to Nashville
because we knew we needed a pedal steel,
but then he was like,
hey, I got this guy I know, Alex Stroll.
Who's who's in LA.
Oh yeah.
He's like a multi-instrumentalist
and he can play a mean electric guitar,
but he also can play the pedal steel.
He can play the mandolin.
He can play the banjo.
This dude can play anything with strings.
And so that pedal steel is Alex is like,
it was passed down to him.
He's got all these instruments
that were passed down
to him that are so old.
Such a great move to have.
So it has that like old school feel,
which was very important to me.
I mean this song,
it definitely has this
kind of Lord Huron vibe,
which I absolutely love.
And then, so like from a production,
instrumentation standpoint and it,
having heard another song from the album,
I know that it,
it doesn't just stay
squarely in this place,
which is also exciting.
So I'm just talking about this song,
not the album or the
other song I've heard.
But that is true.
That the album in itself that this is,
there was a reason that this was,
again, I wrote this song
after I had written almost every song.
I think I only wrote one
more song after this one.
And it was like,
I want this to be the thematic
and conceptual introduction
to what the album is about,
which we can get into in a second,
but probably more important
getting to what you're saying is,
I want this to be a
sign to people who care
about this type of music, that
this is a serious endeavor.
And it, yeah.
Mission accomplished.
I think it sounds great.
It's definitely something that
if I stumbled on this song,
I would be like, what the hell?
I'd have to send it to you.
You'd send it to me.
Again, that was the thinking.
This is something that we would be.
In terms of a genre,
like Indie Western Folk,
which that Lord Huron pocket,
there's other people doing it,
but they're my favorite.
So I didn't say the word country,
but then your vocals come
in and I'm like, oh .
The first thing I thought
with the very beginning
of this one, and I don't,
I don't like drawing
comparisons, but I was like,
this is a nineties country vocal delivery.
In the opening line, I was like,
I hear Alan Jackson.
And I'm like,
and I knew neither one of us
are huge fans of Alan Jackson,
but he's so squarely nineties
country vocal that like,
and something about
your tone and the melody
of that first line, just evoked
that, not a specific song,
but him as an artist.
Yeah, right.
And then the whole song is
not an Alan Jackson thing.
It actually, it goes very much into, okay,
this is a really good choice.
It's a really strong choice,
for you to say, I'm
gonna sing as a country.
I'm gonna sing country.
I'm gonna sing country vocals.
And the juxtaposition of
that over the production
is really cool.
And it's not a Sturgill Simpson thing,
which like some people might try to draw
that comparison or whatever,
because the vocals are so nineties
that I just think that it's
like a really strong, smart,
I almost said fun choice.
But like, yeah, it's exciting.
It excites me because I feel
like it makes it more unique.
There's people,
I'm not following country
music that closely right now.
But I know that like
the nineties movement
that happens in fashion,
it's happening in country music.
There's like current stars.
You played a song for me
of a current up and comer
who then played a song
that was like very
nineties, intentionally.
Are you talking about Luke Combs
doing the Brooks & Dunn thing?
Oh yeah, that was it.
Luke Combs.
Yeah.
So I love the song
in terms of how it melts
those things together.
And then,
I'm a melody guy, right?
I really like that kind of slinky.
It's kind of a sly melody.
What key is it in?
That song is in G.
I love G.
I don't know.
Something about the melody
line of the verse is like,
I love it.
Well, it's funny because you know, again,
very little of this was calculated, right?
But you had to make a choice
to sing country, right?
No, yeah.
So basically, so this is
how that happened, right?
So with that first song that I wrote,
the Old Letter song,
if you take the accent off of the,
out of the lyrics and I
don't sing with an accent,
then you would be like, okay,
this could be like Gregory
Alan Isakov but folk.
But your demo had the country inflection.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
So from the get go, you
were just singing country.
You were writing a country song.
I'm talking about The Old Letter song.
Yeah, the demo, the
first demo you recorded.
Yeah, yeah.
But what I'm, yeah.
But I made the decision.
I was like, first of all,
there's a little bit of country
in just the way that I talk.
And so there's a little bit of country
in the way that I sing,
but you know how you,
you usually translate and you
make a different decision.
Like I'm trying to embody a
certain character or whatever,
and you gotta have a sound.
And so.
'Cause that's what we do.
It's something that we
very calculated say, okay,
I don't wanna sound like
Weird Al in this song.
I don't wanna sound like a redneck.
That was one of the craziest things
in recording is that in making
the decision to be like,
how do I deliver this is,
me and you have recorded so much music
in so many different genres.
It's like, okay, this is a rap song.
This is a country song.
This is a hair metal song.
And we always just adapt
to whatever the genre is.
And we're very good chameleons
that then you have to
be like, well, I gotta,
that's what every artist
is ultimately doing.
They're like adopting,
you love Cocaine & Rhinestones
and now I've gotten into it.
And it's fascinating hearing,
all the stories about George Jones
trying to figure out how
to sound like George Jones.
Right.
And you find yourself doing impersonations
of other people.
Oh, I really.
I'm trying to sound like
The Avett Brothers there
without thinking about it.
There's an exercise of
trusting yourself to be like,
no, I don't have to like
try to sound like anyone.
And so what is the natural melody
and the natural intonation and expression
that comes from me,
it is a culmination of all the music
that I've consumed and sung
along with all those years.
And that's why when I
start singing in country,
so much nineties melodies come out.
Right.
Because that was when I was coming of age.
And it's a safe choice,
I feel like in terms of like,
if you're gonna get a comparison,
if you're gonna get analyzed,
it's an exciting choice.
So I'm really glad you made it.
It's not, you know, there's.
Well, I guess what I'm
saying is it wasn't a choice.
People might.
Okay.
You started saying nineties
and Derek started saying
nineties, I was like, you know what?
You're right.
I was just like,
I want this track to sound
as old school as I can.
It's got in terms of chord structure,
it gets into a little more,
it's almost like gets
into like Roy Orbison.
Yeah.
Type.
That's what I was really getting at.
It's sort the key question.
The sevenths' kind of drop
in there and stuff like that,
which I love, there's
sevenths all over this album.
That's it.
That's what I was trying
to get at with the G.
And that's not something that you
Which was in there.
Hear a lot in just your
average country song.
Yeah.
Right?
It's got that and then gunner
who did the percussion for this?
Who's like an incredible,
incredible musician,
kind of brought in that
like shuffly rhythm.
Yeah.
Which is not,
when I send a demo over
it's me and a guitar.
Yeah.
You gotta find the groove.
And the woodblock stuff and it's great.
So anyway,
those choices and we're gonna talk,
we'll do another podcast in the fall
once the whole thing's out
to kind of talk more about the music,
but ultimately what I'll say
at this point is that it was
calculated to a degree, but
most of it was just like,
what do I naturally hear in this?
And what sounds good to me
and how do I wanna sing this
naturally with this much,
with as little sort of
acting attached to it.
Yeah.
As possible.
And it turns out that
that is sort of this mix
of old school and nineties country.
And then lyrically,
I'm not asking to you to agree.
I'm just asking you to
believe me, you know?
And then, it's very,
it suits country because
it's kind of matter of fact, you know?
Yeah, yeah, it's very sincere.
There's a sincere,
it's there, it's not,
you can really read into your experience
because it's kind of on
the page in a lot of ways,
but I'm not saying that as a critique,
I think that fits country music really.
And I think it also.
Even though I don't, by the way,
I wouldn't call it a country
album based on this song.
I don't know what I'm
gonna call the album but.
Well, that's the genre that I checked
in the distribution box because it's.
Yeah.
It's good.
It's the only one you can check.
Yeah, that makes sense.
And then maybe like Americana.
Yeah.
As a secondary genre.
So lyrically,
you're really putting yourself out there.
It's not, this song is not veiled.
Very few of them are.
And I think that comes
from the fact that's like.
Sure, you can pray.
That's the first time I heard that lie.
Oh.
And I know your experience,
but I just think it's,
obviously I relate to it so much,
so I just think it's nice.
I do think that people,
having shared our deconstruction stories,
I do think that this will be
a source of comfort to people.
Absolutely.
That's powerful, you know?
The conversations that
we've had at this table
about our spiritual journeys,
I've just been blown away
by how it's helped people.
And so it's so cool that
this is gonna do that too.
And it's gonna do it in a way that,
it's gonna do it in a different way.
Music is so powerful.
It's powerful in a totally
different way than podcasts.
I keep saying exciting,
but that's just what I keep
going back to is that like,
I'm just celebrating the fact
that you're putting yourself out there.
You had enough experience
to know that like,
how much of a risk did
this feel like for you
and on what area?
Because when you,
this song at least is something
that you've already said
a number of times I felt like.
So where is the risk?
Where is the fear?
Well, I mean, I think there's,
it doesn't stay this tame.
Hmm, you know?
There are some, what you
might call angry songs
where I'm just letting my
emotions and the way I feel about.
Are you yelling?
The church.
Not really yelling.
In hypocrisy that I see.
And those things that
get me kind of worked up.
But Garth Brooks yelled in Shameless.
He did.
I'm shameless.
Yeah, and I don't want any
Chris Gaines comparisons.
Appreciate not doing anything.
I didn't say it.
So I think that there's a
little bit of that, but I think
Chris Gains.
People know where I stand.
Every once in a while I
toss a little bomb out
into the pond,
or whatever the analogy,
that's not a good one.
I stir things up.
I kick the hornets nest a little bit
for those people who care to feel offended
by the things that I say.
Let me ask you this question.
It's gonna stir that up a little bit.
Do you,
have you felt like it was
a bigger risk creatively
to like put yourself out there,
by doing this project than what,
or is it what you're saying in the lyrics?
Is it the message that
you're getting across?
Because there's a creative risk involved
in saying, hey, I'm one
half of Rhett and Link.
This is what you know me for.
I'm a comedian,
if it were me, I would have to get over
this hurdle of like, embarrassment.
That would be like,
is there risk there?
Is there fear there?
Has that been part of this.
For better or for worse?
I just always approach things,
just believing that I'm gonna
find some way to pull 'em off.
And it's probably.
Okay.
It's probably a misguided
self-confidence that,
yes, I can do this and I can make an album
that I would actually,
if I were not myself enjoy and like.
Well, I'm not embarrassed for
you now that I've heard it,
I'll say that.
But I mean to, I guess.
But yeah, that moment when you're like,
for the first time here and on GMM,
when you're saying I've
released a country music,
there's a little album,
is there a sheepishness there?
Is there like?
I think from a creative standpoint,
when one of the things
you're most well known for
is like being on your knees
and having your best friend pee
chocolate into your mouth from a fountain
that is next to his penis.
I just don't think there's a
lot of things you can do to
creatively embarrass yourself, honestly.
And in one sense,
I think that gets into one
of the sort of unrealized
motivations to do something like this is,
you know me, I talk about it all the time,
is that I do have this chip
on my shoulder creatively.
There's lots of things that
we want to do collectively
to show people what we
are capable of creatively.
And I think there's always an element
of that in everything that I do.
And so I can't,
I'm not gonna be dishonest with you
and tell you that I believe
in what I've created here.
And I think it's good.
And I think other people will agree.
And there's a part of my
ego that wants you to agree.
Okay, well then I've
struck your ego enough,
but I also think I'm projecting, I guess,
in that if I were in your
shoes, that's how I would feel.
So instead, I think it's,
it's something that's inspiring
about the fact that you have
this confidence,
maybe it comes from a chip
on your shoulder or whatever,
but like, you want to express yourself
in this way and you go for it.
And that's something that,
I could do more of.
So if I am to make this
about me for a second,
I do feel like,
I would be embarrassed at every turn.
Even the thing about talking
about like being a DJ,
I had to make a decision to say,
this is kind of a, this is not.
I had to decide what my
posture was gonna be about it.
Right.
It's like, yeah,
this is something that I'm into
and I'm not gonna be sheepish
or apologetic or embarrassed
by having some sort
of creative outlet or aspirations.
So I think that's where that
question was coming from.
It's more about me than you, but.
No, but I have thought about it.
The the worst case scenario is
people are like this YouTube
guy thinks he's a musician now, who cares?
Right.
Okay.
I've lost nothing.
If you already see me as that,
if you see me as this YouTube guy,
this hack that just stumbled into fame
and isn't really talented, then nothing.
If you already think that,
then you thinking that again
is not a problem for me.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
Is there bigger,
there's bigger risks
content wise in other songs.
Yeah, it gets more explicit, literally.
There's a few FBOs dropped on the album,
to give a hint of that.
Are you nervous about any
of the specifics coming out?
I mean what.
No.
Where's.
No, no.
I mean you wrote a,
you said you wrote a song to your kids.
You wrote a song to your parents.
Well, yeah,
I don't know how much
I wanna talk about the.
I have a great relationship
with my parents,
but the thing that I am conscious of
is that because they are still
very much strong Christians.
and I'm very much a public figure
who has stated that I am not,
and that I'm critical of Christianity,
that makes their life more difficult
than I would like it to be, right?
Because of the way people
in the church are, you know?
And so, and just the way
people in general are,
not to single a out the people
in the church, it's just.
If somebody that you're related
to is talking about what you're all into,
then they become a little
bit of a scapegoat.
And I'm sensitive to that
and in some ways that's
kind of what the song
to them is about.
Well, we can leave that part at that.
'Cause I do think I would like to,
I'm gonna hear the whole
album at some point
and then if we can kind of,
I'm sure we'll revisit this.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But you know, in terms of when
we started talking about it,
I was trying to remember when
that was, do you remember?
'Cause I think there were like hints
of I'm writing some song,
I'm writing some songs
and I just remember the first time
it kinda registered was
maybe you had mentioned it
a few times,
but you had mentioned it in an EP.
I think that's the first
time I was like, what?
Hmm.
You're gonna, okay.
So you're not just writing songs.
You're gonna release songs, you know?
What were you thinking there?
Because again, it's like it,
what you just told everybody
for the past hour is not,
was not the entry point
for our conversation.
We never sat down and you said,
hey, gave me this whole story.
Hmm.
So to me, my experience was,
oh, he's doing this thing he
doesn't want to talk about,
but then he feels like he needs,
apparently it's gaining momentum
'cause he's talking about making an EP.
So now he's mentioning it
to me and I respect it.
Like I have an appreciation for it now,
given what you've said, that is like,
it's a deeply personal
exercise that is an,
an application of therapy that
then you would obviously talk
to Jessie about,
in the same way that
there's plenty of stuff
in my personal journey, in my heart,
in my therapy sessions that I
process myself, first of all.
And then there's much of that,
the vast majority of that,
that I'll bring, that
Christie and I will discuss
and I'll bring her into and then.
So I recognize that then there's
certain things at certain
times that I'll bring you into it.
And it's not even a calculation
of I'm keeping things from you.
It's just that like,
there's only so many hours in a day.
And even though we spend the
majority of them together,
we're always occupied with
the things that we're doing.
Jessie asks me multiple times a week.
Did you talk to Link about so-and-so?
I'm like baby?
No, because we talked
about every other thing,
you know what I'm saying?
Like.
but.
Because we're constantly.
I recognize all that.
Yeah.
But my experience with it was,
it was just a little thing here,
a little thing there, an EP, an album.
And so I'm like without
having the full story,
I think there was a lot of,
well, I'm just left to like,
okay, how am I gonna respond to this?
Yeah, and again, none
of that was calculated.
If I think back and try to figure out
why that was the way that it happened.
I think there is a part of my,
there's a part of me that believes,
and this is just kind of
the way my brain works,
Sometimes talking about something.
the only thing that is good
that comes from talking about
something is talking yourself out of it.
And so I don't like to
talk a lot about things.
I just like to keep doing them.
So you're saying, if you
would've talked to me about it,
you would've talked yourself out of it.
I think that not, again,
I haven't thought about this at all,
but I think that there's a fear that like,
because this doesn't make any sense,
because I don't have time for this,
because this is not necessarily
a good business decision.
If we start talking about it,
to then like talk about it
from a strategic standpoint
or a positioning standpoint,
it may just float away.
It may just not be a priority.
But for me it was like,
this is a personal thing that I'm like,
I'm revisiting on my own time.
Up until very, very recently,
I never did any of this during work hours.
This past couple of months,
there's been a couple of
days where I've been like,
I have to go record this
or I have to do that.
That's kind of gotten
into my regular schedule,
but because it was very something
that I just kept pushing forward
in my free time, so to
speak, free time, air quotes,
I think it was.
There was just this unspoken.
I don't wanna sit down and have
a real serious conversation
about this because I
don't wanna slow it down,
because it's gaining so
much momentum personally.
Not that I thought that you
would talk me out of it,
that's not really what I'm saying.
But I hear you saying that
if we talked about it,
it would very quickly get to like,
what is the feasibility of this?
There's not.
There's not a lot of positives
to it in terms of like
Mythical unless you're
really talking about,
I want to do this as a
solo artist and this,
if it became some Mythical endeavor
from a business standpoint,
there's a lot more questions
that all feel like roadblocks
to this personal project if
we had that conversation.
That's why I took a long time.
I didn't talk to anyone here
about it for the longest time,
for the same reasons.
'Cause like, guys,
you may interpret this as a selfish act,
if I start talking about it.
And you're like,
we're always working so busy
and you're off making your little album.
So you know what I'm saying?
So you didn't bring it
up because it could be,
it could be perceived as like
a threat to the business.
Yeah, now I firmly believe that it is not.
And I have a lot of reasons
for believing that it's not.
I think that the way I
kind of analyze that is,
is funny because what we have
is incredibly unusual.
I actually can't think
of a entertainment duo
where both people are
qualified entertainers
and literally every expression of that
is only in the context of that.
Almost every duo that there's
an example of is just like,
oh yeah and he does his little thing,
his little side hobby thing.
It's like super common, right?
But the main thing they do
is the stuff that they do together.
I always thought that the reason that
that hadn't been the case
up until now is twofold.
Number one, it's like, we just
never have time for anything.
And number two, it just never,
I never had an idea
that it made sense to go
and do by myself until this.
So it isn't like I've been
sitting around thinking.
I find it unusual that we
haven't done anything solo
independently of each
other for all these years.
But I also find it, it kind of makes sense
because there hasn't been,
neither of us have had
something where it's just like,
I've gotta get this into the world.
This is the first thing that came along.
To me, it doesn't feel like
a threat to what we have,
if anything, it feels like,
because it's not a replacement of anything
that we're doing.
Well.
In some ways it feels like another facet
to the Rhett side of Rhett and Link.
Do you know what I'm getting at?
Yeah, I think that there
was, so it was the,
was this a threat to the business strategy
of what we're doing,
but then there's another part that's like,
if I bring this up,
will Link perceive it as a threat
to our creative partnership?
And I thought that.
Or more, or our friendship, I don't know.
Well, and again, while
it wasn't calculated,
if you were to ask me like,
okay, well, all right.
We're gonna have to have
a really long conversation about this.
That is going to, again,
I didn't think this,
but I may have been
thinking it subconsciously.
That's just like, okay,
if we have a conversation about this
at a really early stage, it may
really just get bogged down.
Because now in my mind,
what went from being
this thing that was gaining momentum,
it's so difficult to get things to happen
and bring things into the world.
We know that, right?
And when I subconsciously
perceive that there might be
a conversation or some point
that becomes a point of impasse,
I'm like, I don't wanna have that.
I don't wanna do that.
Let's this actually begin
to become something.
And then we can have a
conversation about it
versus having a conversation
about it a year ago.
Not that we didn't talk about it.
Not that you didn't know
about it, but it wasn't like,
hey, let's sit down and
literally hash this thing out.
'Cause in some ways the other
part of my brain was thinking,
there's nothing to hash out.
Like I'm doing this thing.
If you were doing this thing,
I'd be like, that's awesome.
That's cool, man.
Do it.
Now if it suddenly we can't
do something that we wanna do,
'cause you're doing this, then
we can have a conversation.
But if that's not the
case, just keep going.
If it's making you a better,
more fulfilled person, then
that makes you a better,
more fulfilled comedy partner,
a business partner and friend,
if you're pursuing your
passion and doing something,
that's bringing you joy in life.
So I think that's my,
that's how I feel about it.
Honestly.
That's why I feel like
it's a healthy thing for me
and ultimately for us,
because anything that's healthy for me
is healthy for us and vice versa.
Anything that's helpful
for you is helpful for us.
Is healthy for us.
Yeah, when I hear that
I'm like, is that true?
There has to be an exception
to that rule, right?
Could that just be true across the board?
I actually, that's my gut
reaction to that statement.
I think that,
my preference would've been
to talk about it earlier,
but I think it's,
again, this is more about
me than it is about you.
It's not like,
because I think that that's
true because there's.
If I hear you're making
an EP or doing this thing,
the first thing I'm gonna think,
the first thing I did think was
not, I'm so excited for you.
I want to celebrate this.
It's like, what does this mean for us?
Yeah.
And you know, and it taps
into some insecurity.
And I know that there's,
I don't wanna overblow this
whole abandonment issue thing,
but it's there, right?
That's part of my process but,
we had had conversations about
this related to other stuff.
So actually this project
didn't bring this to a head
as much as like,
when I don't,
we don't have to get
into the details of it.
But my response to this project,
this album of yours,
was shaped by the experience
that we had on Ronstadt.
Hmm.
Because that was the,
the Genesis of that
project was messy, right?
Like literally like the
first email and slacks,
and stuff that was going
around about analyzing
the opportunity to partner
and work on Ronstadt
and be attached to it.
The way that,
that started was just messy.
And it was something that then,
we had to work through it, right?
Well, and meaning that,
when we were first approached about that,
the ask was can Rhett play Ronstadt,
which was not a thing that we had,
like we don't.
Right.
We don't go out pursuing opportunities.
Now we may do.
We both, we haven't done a lot lately,
but we both auditioned for
roles that if we were to,
we'll never get one,
but we do it kind of for fun
and maybe one would come and we would,
oh, Link's gonna be on this show
or Link's gonna make a guest appearance.
And he is not going in as Rhett and Link,
he's going in as Link and vice versa.
So that's been a conversation,
but that was being brought into Mythical
as a Mythical project.
Oh Mythical is gonna
actually help produce this.
But the ask was for
Rhett to play Ronstadt.
Right.
And so how do, what do we,
how do we make this a
Rhett and Link thing?
And that became the
conversation as opposed to,
it's gonna be a Mythical
thing that Rhett is doing.
And then the way that
it became a conversation
was just not smooth, you know?
Yeah.
That we would,
we've talked about it and we have learned
that we would've done
things differently, right?
Yeah.
So I don't wanna,
I just feel like that
gives context to this
because I feel like by moving through that
and growing through that,
we were able to articulate
our desires.
Like you were able to articulate
some of your desires for.
Do we have to do every
single thing together?
We started having
conversations about this.
I think there's a whole
other podcast in here,
I'm just gonna allude to it.
And then yeah,
and then I'm bringing to the table,
well, very early on,
we made this choice that we weren't gonna,
everything we're gonna do,
we're gonna do together.
So it's like, okay, now
are we revisiting that?
And what does that mean?
And how far does that go?
Well, it turns out it's
still, it's not that drastic.
It's just that because of my makeup
and what I'm bringing to the
table, it's scarier for me.
And I think there is a,
in me giving off that energy,
I think when it comes
around to this project,
you're probably gonna have this sense
that I'm gonna be more concerned
about it than excited first.
But we benefited from going through,
getting on the same page
on the Ron Step project,
getting on the same page about
just our approach to things
at Mythical and how,
there's so much in this that I just,
I know I'm flirting with it,
but I guess the point I'm making right now
is that we really had
a series of good conversations
that got us more on the same page.
The mantra of saying when in doubt,
talk it out,
is something that we
really benefited from.
So when, and ironically,
a lot of you doing the
songwriting and stuff
was happening in parallel to all this,
but when it came to a point
of you were ready to talk about it,
then I was in a much
better place to receive it.
Hmm.
And that was even without
the benefit of the entire
backstory that you just shared of like
the personal process of it,
but seeing it as,
not seeing it as a threat to what
we're doing is something
that I can say with,
to the 98th degree that I can.
And that's saying a lot.
And I do think that it's,
if it hasn't been obvious
up until this point.
So this is not me saying
that I want to go and
be a full-time musician.
Right.
I'm not touring.
I don't have time to tour.
Even if I wanted to go
around playing these songs,
I'm not saying I'll never play these songs
for someone for a crowd.
I'm just saying that that's not,
the intention isn't
like, now I'm a musician.
And that's what I do.
It's more like, hey,
this has always been very
much a hobby of mine.
And it'll be cool to have
this sort of ongoing thing.
'Cause I expect to release more music
because it's like, hey, I wrote a song.
Let's record it.
Let's release it.
It's something that I can
responsibly fit into my schedule
and not drop the ball with
what we're doing here.
But just so that this isn't
like I'm going to pursue
career as a musician and that's what I do.
It's more like,
well I was already a musician
and now I'm releasing some
music that is just mine.
Yeah.
And I also started to
realize that over the course
of the pandemic,
when I started the listening
party broadcast on Instagram,
to like take my personal creative outlet
of like listening to music,
making playlist and
turn that into something
that involved our audience,
it was something that I didn't calculate.
And then at the moments, when
I talked to you about it,
I had that sheepish like
this is not really a thing.
'Cause, first of all, it wasn't,
but I felt like we didn't
have like just a clear
conversation about it.
It was more like, yeah,
I'm doing this thing.
It'll be fun.
Oh, I'm gonna do 21 of these,
you know, as it turns out.
And I think you're
different than me in that
I do think you were more inclined
to be encouraging about it
'cause you were doing other stuff to,
you saw a parallel.
I mean, did you?
I mean.
I see a parallel now and
that's helpful for me.
I guess, ultimately what I'll say
is that like a lot of these
things don't cross my mind
unless someone else brings them up.
Okay, yeah.
My disposition is different.
And so like,
I haven't thought about the fact
that you are also doing your own podcast.
Right.
And you know what you saying that
doesn't hurt my feelings
because I know you.
Yeah.
But I think there was a point
when it could have hurt my feelings
and it might have just been
two years, three years ago.
You're saying.
Two years ago.
the fact that it doesn't cross
my mind that you're doing.
Yeah because.
For a project.
Right.
Yeah because.
'Cause you're like,
well, I would care if
you were doing a podcast.
Exactly, right.
Right.
Yeah, and I think, I just,
I think ultimately for me,
it's like, I just have,
I know that we both have so
many independent interests
and desires and things that we want to do
and accomplish that
if those things can happen
and not sacrifice all the things
that we want to do together,
then that's a beautiful thing.
I mean, these things aren't,
this is different because
your podcast with your dad
is a Mythical production.
Well, I was talking
about the listing party.
Yeah.
Which I think the thing that's
the same is also like me
saying, oh, you know what,
I'm pursuing the skill of being a DJ.
If that means I'm gonna
actually get a gig,
being a DJ somewhere
sometime, on my own time,
I'm sure it would be something
that you would celebrate
and you wouldn't think twice about it
in the way that I might
have thought twice about your album,
because it's just like,
it's a hobby, it's an
outlet, it's a side project,
that who knows still
might lead to something.
I do think we can talk about that.
But the thing about the like,
just to put a finer point on
me and being inspired by your
exercise is that in a
way that we're different,
like I haven't given myself permission,
like you say,
we both have all these aspirations,
but we do not have them to the same level.
And that's something that I,
I am drawing inspiration from,
that I could grow in that area.
Like the podcast with my dad is,
is a great outlet.
It's been a highlight of my
week whenever we get together
and do it.
It's a creative outlet.
It is part of Mythical.
It's something that we are doing that,
we split it down the middle, you know?
Well.
But it wasn't my idea,
as far as I can recall
it was Stevie's idea.
And I was like, well,
this sounds like a great idea
that I'm never going to
do was my first reaction.
And then when she kept talking about it.
Definitely, you.
Then my next reaction was this
still sounds like a decent
idea that I'm never going to do.
You had to be kind of dragged into it.
Yeah, and even it's like when,
even once my dad was on
board and it was happening,
like I was like, this isn't really,
we're not really gonna do this.
I didn't give myself permission to say,
do I want to do this?
Or I do wanna do this.
And it might fail.
We might fall flat on our face,
but I'm gonna do it because
I'm excited about it.
I think your encouragement and
like following this journey
for you has been,
it's gotten me,
it's gotten me off the dime a little bit,
not in a, oh ,
if he's gonna do something,
I gotta do something.
But actually in a creative outlet,
just tapping into my desires kind of way,
in like a mostly pure motive
kind of way, you know?
It's not like a tip for tat thing.
Yeah.
So I'm actually like listening
to that song and like being
able to celebrate it and
celebrate what's happening
with this project is, is something
that I'm proud of for me.
So it's not something
that I'm conjuring anymore
outta some sense of obligation.
Right.
And to clarify the James
and the Shame project
is not a part of Mythical,
but the reason that it's
not a part of Mythical
is because I did not
want to make anyone here,
have to work on it.
Cara, our personal
assistant has been helping,
but beyond that,
very few people have been
involved and every single expense
has come outta my pocket,
which I am reasonably certain,
I will not make money from this project.
Yeah, you didn't want me to lose money,
but then hey,
if this gets wildly successful,
you're probably gonna
have to cut me in somehow.
We'll have to talk about it.
So that's the only reason it's not.
And it's also,
this is not a core,
a funny podcast with your dad
is a part of the core,
sort of focus of Mythical,
a serious country album
about deconstruction
is not part of the core
mission of Mythical.
So there's a number of reasons
that it's not a mythical thing.
And that also is one of the
reasons that I don't really work
on it here or with the
people at this company
and I work on it outside of my
normal responsibilities here.
But we're at a point in our career
when we can do things that
are associated with our careers,
that don't involve the other person,
but will be a part of Mythical.
Of course.
So Dispatches from Myrtle Beach
is a great example of that.
Yeah, and I mean.
There may be other things.
There should be other things.
So one of the things we
haven't talked about,
I know we're going a little
bit long, but it's fine.
I think that there, I mean,
I'm interested how you feel
about Dispatches from Myrtle Beach
in regards to this,
because one of the things,
first of all,
I get so creatively frustrated
because as much as we
put out into the world,
there's a lot more that doesn't
make it out into the world
because of limitations,
because we're conceptualizing things
that need to be green lit by people
and they need to be
financed and they have to go
through pitch meetings,
etcetera, etcetera.
And some of the ideas
that I'm most passionate
about that I feel are most representative
of us creatively are things
that we can't just put
out on YouTube for free.
They have to be financed
and it's a different model.
And very few of those things have made it
to where people can enjoy them.
Yeah.
With music.
No one else, like if
I can get somebody to,
I don't even have to get
somebody to produce it.
Like I could just record it,
at the Creative House and release it.
You can just go through Spotify or what,
you just distribute your music.
There's been something so
freeing and life giving in just
something happening, like having an idea.
And then it can just be
birthed and given to the world.
But part of that has been.
And, yep.
Doing it independently
and it not being a collaborative thing.
To me there's been,
it's made me appreciate the
things that are collaborative.
And I've also just, hey, this is on me.
I gotta finish this.
I have to be the one to make the call.
I've got to make these
decisions and move this forward.
And then also like do a bunch of things
that I haven't done in years.
Like I designed the artwork
for the first single.
I don't design artwork.
Yeah, I was very surprised.
But I was like, I don't
wanna pay somebody else.
I'm paying so many people
to do so many parts of this.
I don't wanna pay
somebody else to do this.
It feels like I can figure this out,
but there's been something very rewarding
about just conceptualizing
and executing something and putting it
on into the world on my own.
I haven't done that in so long.
Yeah.
There's been something personally
rewarding in doing that.
Not because it's like, oh,
finally I get to do something on my own.
It's just like,
oh no, I made a decision
to do this on my own.
And it's been life giving
in a different way than a collaboration.
Yeah.
I think that fans of ours,
Mythical Beasts will ask.
Yeah, but I mean, why?
There's backup, there's harmony.
Why didn't you get him to sing some,
why didn't you get sing some
harmony on that, you know?
And that was very specifically
a calculated decision.
Talk about that.
Because.
'Cause we haven't talked about that,
but I I'm reading between the lines and I.
Yeah, because when I sing
melody and you sing harmony,
that's a Rhett and Link song.
This isn't a Rhett and Link project.
And I don't want people to think,
it needs to be its own thing, right?
It doesn't need to be like,
oh, Rhett and Link also
made a country album.
Right.
No, no, no.
It's just not a Rhett and Link thing.
It's a Rhett thing.
And that's okay.
And you know what?
It's good is what I'm saying.
Sure, you would've been great at it.
I think that, but I,
but even from a Sonic's standpoint,
I want it to feel like its own thing.
Me and you singing together
is a very specific,
great and beautiful thing.
But it's a Rhett and Link thing.
I don't wanna take the
Rhett and Link thing
and spread it over into this,
that cheapens the Rhett and Link thing.
And it cheapens the James and
the Shame thing, you know?
And so I want this to
have a signature sound.
So like in that song that
we listened to today,
that's Derek singing.
He's great vocalist.
That's him singing the backup lyrics.
But there are songs where
I sing my own harmony,
when it makes sense thematically.
There are songs were Jessie sings harmony,
where it makes sense thematically.
But the thing that did,
if I had a song about you on the album,
then it would make sense for,
you know what I'm saying?
Then it would make sense for you
to sing the song.
It was like the, to me,
it was about theme.
Unless it's about me being dead.
And standing on its own.
And it was like, hey,
at one point it became
almost out of principle.
Like, I don't want Link to
hear this until it's done
because it's not a Rhett and
Link thing, not outta spite,
but because of all the reasons
that we've just covered.
And it's like, I don't
wanna complicate that.
I don't wanna complicate
that and muddy that.
If it really is Rhett thing,
then let it be a Rhett thing
and something that then I can just
kind of present to you and you can enjoy.
And honestly, I've been treating
Dispatches from Myrtle
Beach the exact same way.
Like I haven't,
I am at the time that
we're recording this,
the first episode's about to drop.
And that's when I'm gonna
listen to it for the first time,
I'm gonna listen to it as a fan
of listening to you and your dad talk,
not as somebody who's a
producer and it's gonna be like,
well, let me give you
some feedback on that.
Do you know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
And to me, there's something healthy
about that separation.
I respect that, I understand that.
Is there anything else
that you wanted to share?
I don't think so.
Obviously, I'll use this time to say
that I am genuinely interested
in a lot of people hearing this.
And so it gets to the people
who it will impact in the way
that I would like to see them impacted.
So do all the things that
you do with the musicians
that you like, you know?
Listen to it, follow me on those places.
I am creating, like.
I think you should refer
to it in the third person.
I'm creating James and the Shame profiles
in different places, but
only as placeholders.
So people don't steal them,
but all updates about this are gonna come
through all my initial social channels.
So you can go like follow those place,
those accounts over there,
just so that somebody
will be following them,
but it's primarily gonna just
be done through all my stuff.
But I would like, it would do nothing.
It would do my heart very,
very well for somebody out
there who likes this kind.
The only reason they're
listening to what I'm doing
is because they like the music.
And then they're like,
this guy's not singing about the stuff
that I typically listen
to in country music.
This guy seems to be challenging.
It would be cool if it
developed a life of its own.
Yeah.
And that again is,
that's my desire is that this thing
has a home in people who
will relate to the story
that I'm telling.
And so if you think you
know somebody who is like,
I've never sent anything to this person,
because I know they're not
gonna like X, Y, and Z,
that these guys have done.
If you're like, oh, they might
like this, send it to 'em.
So that's what I would
ask the Mystical Beasts
is just like, give it a chance.
Don't see it as a threat.
Hopefully what we've talked about today,
if that was your concern,
that you understand that this is about
personal expression and
ultimately a healthy thing
that is not a existential threat
to Mythical or anything Rhett and Link,
if anything an enhancement
to what we're doing here,
but also share it with people
who you think might like it.
That's all I'll say.
Awesome.
Alright, I think you're
supposed to have a rec.
Are you recking your own single?
Man, I can't.
It seems like you kinda have to.
Just do it.
Just rec your own single.
Yeah, I recommend that you go over.
What's it called?
It's called, Believe Me.
And at some point,
hey, I am gonna have,
there's gonna be some
James and the Shame merch.
I don't know if that'll be the case
by the time this goes up.
Nipple clamps?
There's gonna be some of that as well.
So you can spread the word.
G strings?
I'll just say,
just follow me where
you listen to your music
and listen, put it in a playlist,
whatever you do with music.
Alright.
Next week, we'll talk at you.
#earbiscuits.
Hi, Rhett and Link.
I was just listening to the
podcast where you're discussing
keeping the shower curtain open
or closed when you're done with it.
I'm very passionate about
keeping the shower curtain open
because I don't want a serial
killer to be hiding behind it.
Just thought I'd mention it.
'Cause I didn't know the default
was to keep it close all the time.
So I'm here to say,
keep your shower curtains open
so that there's no serial
killers, thank you, bye.
Hi, Rhett and Link.
My name is Molly.
I just wanted to let you guys
know that I just had dental
surgery and was listening to your podcast
while I was breathing
in the nitrous oxide.
And for a couple minutes there,
I transformed myself into
the table of dim lighting
and I saw you two and also Stevie.
So it was a very weird experience,
but I'm very grateful for it.
You guys got me through
the surgery, so thanks.
Hey Rhett, hey Link.
My name is Jesse.
I live in Sugar Grove, Ohio.
I've been a fan for a long time,
but I'm only calling in to say,
Link. I think the funniest thing
about Dispatches from Myrtle Beach
is the pain that you feel when your dad
says certain things.
I'm listening to episode two
and he was explaining the metal
fan talking about that metal rock music
and your pause was the funniest thing.
So I just, I love it.
Keep doing what you do, guys.
Bye.
To watch more Ear Biscuits
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your Mythical Best.